so you met Charles Manson in prison
didn't you what was that story can you
tell us that in the county jail let me
tell Charlie wasn't the guy that you saw
on the TV special and he was like five
foot five little chronic he was poor
kind of like a bum really we found out
that he could hypnotize you so we let
him sleep in front of ourselves to make
sure that nobody would hurt him
everybody else had like six guys in
their show we only had three because we
were special had two killers with me so
and then he got his loaded on I said
well get his loaded on him he got two of
us loaded on one guy just woke up and
afterwards I asked him how come we
couldn't do him and he said did you ever
get loaded on no your mind doesn't know
how to react if I tell you to do
something while you're hypnotized and
you haven't done it before you'll just
wake up so you're saying that he got you
guys loaded up but there was no I know
in the room right he was doing this
purely through hypnosis so you've
basically got unlimited access to
anything that you want because he can
just keep on hypnotizing you back into